[Music]
apparently Friday the 13th
oh my God
oh my God
okay happy Friday the 13th Ghouls and
goblets uh welcome to the break room
your daily nerded news nerdy news show
uh it tells you what you need to know uh
live from New Rockstar's actual break
room we're starting to have a little
silly here uh and later we might put on
costumes
uh with me here for this special holiday
edition we've got uh Brandon Barrick
Myers I don't recognize Friday the 13th
oh okay uh we've got uh Tommy bechtold
Myers
welcome to my Pike mirror hi come here
hi come here yeah I'll fix it in post
this isn't live is it and then uh I'm a
set of Satan himself uh biazel's uh Zach
um but uh on today's show uh grogu gets
on the Gridiron oh Yellow Jackets teaser
oh hell yeah songs to die for and much
much more it's gonna be a mostly horror
themed show today in honor of Friday the
13th yeah
um our first Friday the 13th of 2023.
yeah uh we don't have a particular Super
Chat Redemption today but we will read
out everybody that super chats we will
try to acknowledge you if you have any
particular horror takes we will
prioritize those because of one of your
biggest fears this Friday the 13th oh
yeah if there's anyone that you just
want killed give us their address whoa
if you're super chat's high enough and
you give the address we'll consider it
yeah okay consider it there's a hidden
menu on our page find it
it's got a protein style uh murder
Flying Dutchman murder
um okay hey let's do some headlines okay
please
uh this Monday January 16th a couple
days from now uh during the Cowboys
Buccaneers Wild Card NFL game we're
getting a new trailer for Mandalorian
season three oh I think have we do we
have we had a full trailer I know around
Star Wars celebration there was some
footage there was like a full trailer I
think I believe it's like at least a
minute yeah you see a lot of Mandalore
they called it a teaser at the time I
remember the awarding but it was they
showed real to me in the old days teaser
was like give me an old 98 Old footage
with like voice over from the character
that had never aired in anything and
then like five seconds at the end of
something new and shocking now teasers
are basically just trying little trailer
Juniors yes so we can expect we're
hoping for a lot of new footage maybe
some hints of what's going to go on in
this season uh I want to see the scooter
gangs
candy paint chrome scooter gang uh I
heard like poochie they died on their
way back home
um so supposedly this is gonna come out
during halftime of the game of course
we're going to be doing some coverage of
that trailer uh Eric Voss who's back
from vacation we'll be doing a full
breakdown Tommy might do some content
around that trailer we might talk about
on the break room we're excited a
reminder that this season season three
of the Mandalorian we'll see din jar in
and grogu on Mandalore we have never
been in live action we've never been to
Mandalore is that right I'm so excited
to get to Mandalore and I'll be honest
if God willing this channel is going to
let me do some Mandalore content because
yes I'm a Mandalore Amanda horror I
gotta be honest can I put you on the
spot you Amanda [ __ ] okay
there was the flashback we see of din
Jordan I Believe in the first season
where there's
s is going down yeah when he's a little
kid okay Civil War I see because that's
where they find him he's a foundling I
believe not and I don't mind being put
on the spot and you know what call in if
I'm wrong if he's wrong but I believe
that that is the pl his home planet and
it was an example of the war escalating
right now because then at the end when
the mandalorians show up and kind of
save it save him and some of his people
they take him back to me more presumably
and the mandalorians are kind of
fanatical and constantly predicting like
uh apocalypse and end of days real fun
group yeah well if there's one thing
history's taught me is this there's
nothing wrong with a good religious
fundamental well and also like I think
like really if the mandalorians were on
a planet that celebrated Halloween
they'd be the house with the locked
doors and no lights that's right that no
candy out front
um Candy just prayers
producer John's saying that that was
that's where the flashback scene in
season one was John
um okay uh and again reminder season
three debuts on Disney plus starting
March 1st so we're about the Ides of
March about 45 days out uh from Matt
really excited uh we're of course gonna
be covering Mandalore and uh the
Mandalorian season three
I can't wait new Star Wars stuff baby
you know for me I'm always like uh like
a like a beautiful caterpillar waiting
in his Chrysalis to be a Star Wars
butterfly I feel like I've been in my
Chrysalis for a long time it's been a
minute it's been a minute since Andor
ended again this this year 2023 we're
getting Mandalorian season three we're
getting Ahsoka and we're getting uh
Skeleton Crew is scheduled for the end
of the year hopefully it doesn't get
pushed or anything like that but we
should get three full Star Wars series
not to mention animated stuff bad batch
going on right now I think we're getting
what's the other uh the Star Wars uh
Siri animated series that drops on uh
the little Standalone episode thingy
hotels with the Jedi tales and the Jedi
I think you're getting more of that I
think I don't know
um but it's gonna be an exciting year
for Star Wars content uh it's also
rumored that tickets for Ant-Man of the
WASP quantumania will go on sale during
the Monday night game so we might get a
a new TV a couple new shots yeah
probably we use a lot of footage but
maybe some new shots tickets on sale
it'll be Kang going we only have one
movie theater here in the quantum realm
and it only shows Ant-Man quantity what
if it's Scott saying I don't have to buy
the ticket as long as neither of us buys
that yeah
um uh a third property that maybe is not
as familiar with our audience but we are
very judgment uh we got a teaser for the
second season of yellow jackets and now
the first season Yellow Jackets is out
there that was on that was a Showtime
series sorry Christina Ricci
um Juliette Lewis among others a great
show it's got a little sci-fi element
it's got a little horror elements to it
uh some action it's great we're really
jazzed for the second season uh and the
trailer premises more Supernatural
mysteries for the high school soccer
team stranded in the wilderness of
course we get Elijah Woods is wood uh
not multiple Elijah Woods uh just one
alone your Woods are we getting I can't
see that I can't see the forest for the
woods yeah he's joining he's joining the
series yeah I'm very excited to have him
on it yeah I love this show that Series
starts March 24th we're not sure the
extent to which we're going to cover it
on the channel we hope it's a big hit
and we can do some coverage of it on new
rockstars yes I mean we're regular
Yellow Jack offs and we want to do it
stop we want in
we want in
happy Friday everybody happy Friday
Friday the 13th uh oh and speaking of
episodic series we're very excited about
we are 48 hours oh yeah a little bit
over 48 hours away from the first
episode of HBO's The Last of Us series
uh it starts this Sunday we are going to
be doing a full after show this is
actually news for the break room uh
Mondays for the next 10 weeks roughly uh
we're gonna convert the break room on
Mondays to a last of us after show okay
so watch last of us so you know what
we're talking about
um we'll be it's gonna be Jessica Anna
vanston and
probably me and probably Brandon are
going to be hosting that so Mondays um
also it might be coming out a slightly
different time than you're used to if
you're showing up at 3 P.M Pacific uh
sometimes 305 sharp yeah uh you might
not see us here live but trust that
we'll be back uh Tuesday through Friday
normal time content because guess what
now we got Monday to cook yes now Monday
we can do we can do some crock pot
stories you know what I'm saying set it
out high and forget about it oh yeah let
it simmer uh and that's something we're
gonna try out a little bit more this
year of using the break room as like
kind of a flex after show format if
there are some really big shows you're
excited about let us know and you know
if possible we might kind of do one day
a week of the break room that we treat
as an after show for that series and
then the other four days that week will
treat like the normal break room with
headlines and mandatory fun and all the
great stuff sorry just to get a quick
live break in here we have some live
data uh will you be watching
Yellowjackets season two 28 percent said
yes okay 71 says I like to lick Frozen
uh poles outside when it's below
freezing temperatures to get my tongue
stuck because that's the level of
intelligence I have I stick my hot
tongue on a cold pole all the time I am
a dumb boy or a girl uh so that's the
results 28 of you will be watching uh
the rest of you will be sticking your
warm tongues on cold poles needing the
police to intervene because you're just
dummies no no well and and you know what
again I always say this one people
aren't into this stuff we like yet I
look you know like the people that
didn't watch Andor or whatever hey
you've got a great thing ahead of you I
know you're not into it yet but you have
uh uh you know the potential to get into
it in the future you know it's also the
possibility that people don't have
Showtime yeah I only have show time
that's a good point look out there for
some specials some deals on like free
trials share passwords guys yeah hit up
your parents
it hurts the union when you don't when
you share your password but listen to me
like my cousin used to say whenever I I
would would ever I would say I didn't
like something well you're just too
young to understand it when you're older
you'll get it and speaking of getting it
how how fresh can get it I like them for
sponsoring all week long
has been a priority for me so far this
year as you know I have two fitness
goals fit on all the rides at Universal
Studios and fit into one of those Verity
uh the iconic sweatshirts or whatever
they're called and guess who's making
that happen for me Hello friends yeah
hellofresh makes dinner time easy with
Fast and Furious and fresh recipes
hellofresh also has a line of delicious
filling meals that are ready in less
than 15 minutes that's right even you
short attention span people that can
only watch Quick YouTube videos two
quickies and you got a sick chicken
dinner in the oven enjoy taste and
quality done quick because recipes like
Sesame beef tacos Thai spiced pork
meatballs and you know one that kind of
threatens me but also makes me feel
excited winner winner orzo chicken
dinner you know what it's all right to
be scared when you eat think about those
girls in yellow jackets
love hello fresh and we use them many
many times I've talked about my family
Dynamics changing and had a lot of
depressing messages but going into the
weekend I'm gonna be a little freak end
and you know what I'm gonna start look
at hellofresh for three hoping the two
ladies join me at the time oh no here's
the good part hello fresh is America's
number one meal kit and you should try
it for yourself go to hellofresh.com
break room 22 and use code break room 22
4 22 free meals plus free shipping
that's not 21 free meals it's 22. oh so
you go to hellofresh.com break room 22
you got to use the code to help us feed
you get those 22 free meals what are you
doing you serious yes 22 free meals
Tommy that's 44 potential women you
could draw oh my God
wait wait how does that work Rachel Ruth
Bethany Han Sol
Kirsten Kristen uh Eve uh Persephone uh
I'm trying to think of people who want
blood relatives okay damn you're hanging
uh it is Friday the 13th uh if you
didn't know watch your back check check
your back seat when you get in the car
this evening okay
and in honor of Friday the 13th we
wanted to talk about some of the most
anticipated horror movies and series
upcoming in 2023 and I would like to say
to you folks at home that I'm doing this
under duress because I hate scary movies
I'm a little scary boy and I'm scared uh
but
before we get to the list of great
horror films uh we have some
late-breaking horrifying news last night
Tommy our beloved Tommy Bechtel was
killed on National streaming television
I mean we have a clip of it whoa
thank you
for your consideration ladies and
gentlemen for everybody who says I have
a fat ass not anymore
wow that was Tommy in season two of
Hunter streaming now on Amazon Prime
look for me on episode seven folks and I
do so much more than that I go to the
bathroom
everyone to see my thick thighs this is
the episode for you yeah you ever not
wanted to fast forward back also your
fresh face yeah I haven't seen you not
bearded in a minute yeah that was the
that was that brief period of time where
many of my YouTube comments were like I
don't like the way your face looks
without a beard so I have obliged it
brought the beard back so uh but but
watch that uh yes please do we hope uh
well we would say we hope they bring him
back to season three but well who they
could do it because that you said that's
like a flashback yeah maybe my son
Avengers or whatever they go further
back in the past let me see your origin
stories I think they do need Matthias
loons Origins
from my front here uh you know me German
word I had to learn for that show was
watermelon yeah oh delicious everything
else tables tablecats beautician uh now
this year has a lot of scary content and
I'm not just talking about the news
folks from C equals a remakes of Legacy
franchises to brand new stories to make
you sleep with the lights on so we're
gonna get uh we we have these knives
here we have we each have five knives
five real knives uh and as we go
throughout the upcoming films and TV
series we'll be stabbing the ones we're
most excited okay so we'll keep we'll
keep track of the ones we like the most
uh and we'll we'll throw out our knives
for those so the first one I want to
talk about first horror movie knock at
the cabin it's coming out next month
next February uh this is the M Night
shadow um
yeah yes David Batista Dave Batista
Batista and Dave Batista is I think very
excited about his performance like feels
like you really got to deliver some
monologues in this and yeah I for one am
excited to see it I'm Rupert Grant isn't
it Ronald Weasley
this is a kind of horror movie I like a
little more less less leaning on the
gore presumably Leslie leaning on more
Thriller mystery kind of psychological
Thriller like uh it's very like um 10
Cloverfield Lane like these people are
kind of Trapped In This cabin with these
people who show up and they are telling
them that the world's gonna end but it's
like do you believe what they're saying
well in knowing Shyamalan maybe they're
right maybe there's a Twist maybe the
world ends maybe there's not uh we are
pretty excited for this we might we're
probably going to cover this on the
channel yeah multiple ways that trailer
I think we've only gotten uh one trailer
for it maybe a second trailer is on its
way soon but um yeah we're pretty
excited this week next we gotta mention
Scream Six yeah New York City taking
place on a subway line which I believe
like this device yeah kind of like this
trapped in this space is moving uh
coffin uh and it's taking place during
Halloween I believe so like multiple
people in the costume you don't know
what's real what's not Jenna Ortega is
returning uh to this film uh I'm not so
keen on my screen franchises I need to
re-watch UNC screen five no no it was a
lot of fun I've seen scream 2. that's it
that's it give it to me scream one no I
don't like scary movies either I've seen
dollars the same world all the same
University I've seen all the screams I
really enjoyed Scream 5 Jack Quade from
the boys real fun so step five was
called scream right it was just called
scream I used to make my mom make uh
director's cuts of scream called whisper
and it'll just be people going you're
okay
two franchises hitting their tenth
editions this year uh this is not spiral
Spiral was separate yeah that's gonna be
a prequel Tobin Bell is returning uh and
they might include some more flashbacks
of him he I believe the the jigsaw died
in saw three but there have been like
copycat killers and like flashbacks to
him yes this is gonna be more of a
prequel we don't know if saw 10 is the
final title of the chemical again you
know okay what's crazy about this
Brandon is that up until now a sequel to
saw nine was not something that had been
heavily saw 10 after oh God damn worth
it
yeah but uh that'll be interesting again
I didn't see the spiral the uh Chris
Rock kind of offshore what was it called
spiral a saw story or something like
that
um
wow Ron Howard did step in to fix that
one right
um then uh another trailer we got
recently Renfield uh starring Nicholas
Holt and Nicholas and Nicholas Cage two
Nicks twin Nicks uh with Nicholas Hull
playing like uh Dracula's familiar
Nicholas Cage playing Dracula it looks
like it's aquafina's in there as well
looks like it's kind of like a comedy
action I don't know how scary it's gonna
be no sorry it's from Universal so it's
a big Studio Movie yeah I I like you
know this is again more my speed kind of
like the menu right it's more of a
probably a send up before movie tropes
yeah celebrating that but as as a
vampire movie I hope there's tons of
Gore yeah yeah I think comedy as weird
as it is I'm with you I don't like
really gory horror movies but when
there's a comedy element like Shawn of
the dead or something like that right I
the gorg becomes funny to me for some
reason I don't know why maybe they're
not like the other guys a little less
tension uh and now uh going maybe a
little less Gore but a lot of
uncomfortableness we have Bo is afraid
Ari Astor who did hereditary and
mid-somar uh this is his new movie
starring Joaquin Phoenix and trailer
just came out last week and it is weird
as hell it is so weird this looks like
uh you know it's got some Charlie
Kaufman elements to it maybe some kind
of weird meta psychological trippy kind
of stuff going on uh Joaquin Phoenix
seems to age like 100 years over the
course of it starts he's a child then he
becomes a very old man at one point and
there's some like weird people with
rubber faces and there's a lot going on
in this we're excited I mean this
director has a pretty high hit rate both
those those previous two movies were
awesome
sneaky like hereditary and Midsummer are
so scary and like intense and weird in
this movie you're right it does feel
more like a Charlie Kaufman kind of
maybe a personal story reflection on his
own mortality silly and like strange and
storybooky I don't know but it could be
secretly have we seen Joaquin Phoenix in
a horror movie
uh yeah he was in not a horror movie but
that eight millimeter was like a real oh
touche that was very dark speaking of
Nicholas Cage yeah uh I mean there are
some scary parts of Joker oh yeah uh I
mean I think some would say walk the
line was terrifying for Johnny Cash's
children uh if you're if you're uh
scared of uppers yeah not me
you were never really here oh that's a
good point that's a really good movie
for maybe three or four years ago uh
yeah
um Insidious five is coming out they're
already up to five Insidious flights I
mean when's the end guys how Insidious
do we have to be before we become city
is
out city is more like it no but of
course the the James Wan started
franchise James one who now mostly kind
of produces every other horror movie in
Hollywood including Megan that just came
out earlier this month uh but this is
part of that big franchise against this
takes place this takes place 10 years
after the original and follows one of
the kids as he goes to college and Zach
if you don't mind can I take the next
one because I'm actually I have an
interview with entertainment you're one
of their new hosts uh for for movie news
slide over Whoopi Goldberg there's a new
Sister Act in town the nun too a sequel
in The Conjuring universe will be
hitting theaters I guess your move uh
whatever the name of Kathy and Jimmy if
you're gonna make a sister act three
let's go one thing I know is these
sisters sure can act
another sequel on The Conjuring Universe
yeah I hope they hire me Billy bush has
been there for too long oh uh too long
is right oh uh well-rounded mom said in
a super jab pointing out Joaquin was in
the village
good work signs too and signs he's been
in a couple of shots Swing Away Meryl uh
thank you well around mom great Point
um now you know you could argue again
some of the traveline movies are we
seeing signs as a horror movie probably
not but uh there's Sean is it it's his
own it's his own genre Thriller yeah
they have a bird costume bird monster in
the village that's right and until you
until you get the secret of the movie
revealed to you you're pretty scared
which I just did do you guys think one
of the people in the village was a
former member of the Jim Henson Creature
Shop
[Applause]
I'm gonna make a little something for us
from the shop before I leave it'll be in
my car that we keep in the garage for a
while anyway the toughest thing about
living in the village would be like
people
constantly claiming to invent something
you have to be like we know that's
something else yeah you didn't remember
that look at this I've made a a cup that
can Mash together different foods to
make
liquid I'm calling it a blender
we've been just like washing your hands
you'll be like shouldn't we be washing
our hands we know that's a good idea and
they're like well technically we're not
supposed to know you have to keep
[ __ ] on them to make them strong or
or like all the people that are like
I've just composed a new song
Hello darkness this is my own friend
speaking of songs more on that a little
bit oh yeah yes uh we also have another
trailer we got recently Evil Dead rise I
am not watching you that was a dress
that made me watch the trailer and I
went
I'm not watching along the lines maybe
not quite as bad as terrifier 2 that
I've watched too many clips from to ever
sleep again but Evil Dead rise this is
produced by Sam Raimie of course who
directed Evil Dead Evil Dead 2 an Army
of Darkness kind of the original trilogy
in this there was a reboot a few years
ago I believe like 2018 they redid the
Evil Dead and and I think this is in
that Universe yeah uh Jessica pointed
out that like some things from uh that
movie appeared in this trailer I think
to kind of confirm that it was the same
universe or like a follow-up to that and
same Remy is not directing this film he
did produce it and but definitely the
trailer had some Sam Ranger images some
of those uh those quick Zoom Dolly shots
when my daughter can't fix hey your
mother's sleeping with the mother
it looks wild uh oh and then uh speaking
of uh sequels to franchises uh we're
getting the Exorcist on Netflix yes this
is a so they made the original The
Exorcist then they made two sequels this
is discounting the two sequels that have
already come out this will be a sequel
to the original Exorcist uh I think the
mom's coming back from The Exorcist to
be in this one so as a direct sequel
from that and I think they want to make
another movie after this one yes I think
I think Netflix is already paid for two
yeah I don't know if they'll keep the
name The Exorcist or if that's just what
it's called as of right now again very
much like scream five being called
scream very confusing and these are
these are produced by Jason Blum of Blum
House who they just did Megan uh they've
done the purge movies he has uh the
Invisible Man he's got a pretty great
track record for horror movies in the
last 10 years
um so we're excited about this it stars
uh what's his name from Hamilton
um with three names no the other guy
with three names oh Leslie Odom Junior
yes from uh
yeah body Crouch Jr
uh speaking of songs
um uh oh they were also getting uh
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey oh
Father
Christopher Robin
the story behind this movie is almost as
much fun as whatever the movie will be
uh does he kill with no pants oh uh
we'll have to find out uh again the
Winnie the Pooh uh uvra went into the
public domain recently it's been out 100
years and so uh both the estate of uh AA
Milne and Disney or whatever they don't
own those characters anymore anybody can
use them as they're in the public domain
so somebody went and made a horror movie
out of them I apologize for my poon is
showing I'm going to kill you
uh the trailer looks wild people in
costume killing you know yeah it looks
gross uh I think I thought they were the
actual character I didn't think there
were people wearing I really did I'm
sorry guys I thought they got a real
Pooh Bear yeah I thought they fought a
real bad no no you know what I mean I
thought they were actually being Winnie
the Pooh not like psychos oh no I think
they are being here well I don't know I
haven't seen the movie I just watched
the trailer they don't make it clear
yeah yeah it doesn't seem like a uh
because it's such a simp
we're also getting a haunted mansion
remake that's not really scary though no
probably not but there will be Jared
letters in it
right uh of course this would be based
on the Disneyland ride uh follows a
psychic exercising the house we'll be
starring Rosario Das and Daniel DeVito
Tiffany haddish Owen Wilson and lakeith
Stanfield okay there's no Jared Leto in
that lineup is he in the movies I
thought he was playing one of the ghosts
one of the like singing ghosts I think
he's just a ghost to all the cast
members scaring them and haunting yeah
yeah maybe what I heard is he was
showing up and screwing with the cast
members signature breaks if you don't
remember they did a haunted mansion
Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy uh when at the
height of Pirates of the Caribbean like
let's turn all our rides into the movies
didn't really just go out but I I guess
I I think this will totally replace that
movie as far as I know
yeah I don't know I think the only one
of those movies that really worked for
me was The Enchanted Tiki Room you like
that one huh yeah what happened was it
wasn't released in theaters this guy
just brought me into a shed and started
throwing bird corpses at me
was it enchanting
well Wired Magazine said oh Robert what
does a profit a man to gain the world
that loses soul
and the tiki Tiki okay
we're also getting out this is a movie
that's been delayed a few times it's not
I don't think it's technically slated
yet but the hope is gonna come out this
year okay the killer from David Fincher
uh whose last movie was mank in 2021 uh
Bank stank no get at him
and yeah David Venture who's brought us
the game uh Fight Club obviously 8937
some of the best he does not want you to
bring up alien three hey hold on
hold up I think it's pretty great uh
cocaine there directed by Elizabeth
Banks from Charlie's Angels
but uh supposedly this movie it follows
an assassin it's an original story it
follows an assassin that begins to
psychologically crack as he develops a
conscious conscience even as his clients
continue to demand his skills
um we demand it yeah but it looks great
skills and of course um zodiac another
great David Fincher that movie holds up
that movie is is remains one of the
scariest movies I've ever seen and still
freaks me out I remember being in a
theater the daylight kill in that movie
is so haunting yes just brutal that like
oh use of Music
there at that sequence that's worth the
rewatch that might be a future uh break
room Movie Club entry right there and
then finally um no this I don't know
there's some scary elements in the
trailer but cocaine Bears coming out
this year it's another movie from
Universal uh as Tommy pointed out if
it's directed by Elizabeth Banks it is
that right by Elizabeth Banks uh cast of
a thousand people this trailer I don't
know which has uh more actors in it uh
Megapolis or this movie like I can't
tell reminds me of movie 42 where
Elizabeth Banks went around town is like
you owe me five lines in a movie you
gotta be in cocaine hey
you want to be in cocaine bear uh so you
wanna you wanna throw out some knives
yes
we each have five weekend toss out is
that one out like off the bat off the
bat and you know it was fresh maybe it's
recency biased right but like the killer
man yeah I think you gotta bet on
Fincher coming back to the theaters with
a hot one or maybe in theaters this
might be a Netflix joint but uh I will
give like three of my knives three yeah
whoa I'm hot on Finch hot on Finch I'm
gonna go I got a two for here if you
don't mind okay please feel free to join
me
I'm gonna go I'm gonna give two
to scream six yeah
let me give two Jenna Ortega The It Girl
of the moment she's throwing a little
shade at Lady Gaga the other day at the
Golden Globes and then I'm gonna give
one to Renfield because I want to cover
it on this channel yeah so this is just
a little bit of personal manifestation
Nicholas Holt come on the show
what's the whole top Nicholas Cage come
on the show wouldn't it be sick if we
got that's when we know that we've
succeeded at this company
um I want to throw some love and knock
at the cabin I want to throw some love
at Beau is afraid ooh
the cabin too or are we only getting
around no no you could pass them out
wherever you want okay I'm putting one
next to Zach's because I feel safer in
the in the chat tell us tell us put
knives in the chat for what you think is
going to be the hottest of these movies
and I gotta say it already came out in
2023 otherwise it would be on here Megan
would have been getting some knives from
us too and the menu also I'm gonna put
one down for this Exorcist we brought
that up right what this exercise
oh The Exorcist okay sorry yes Tommy
okay sorry about that yeah I'll throw it
on okay she got a bet on the exercise
yeah he's always been on The Exorcist
I made the knives too big I think uh
were the titles too small it doesn't
matter
um now you need a big knife if it's a
horror movie
um yeah okay any others we had uh Blood
and Honey Haunted Mansion Evil Dead rise
the nun two Insidious five saw ten I got
a bad feeling about saw 10 although I
guess they saw loyalists that'll always
see it
but other than that yeah I'm not I guess
evil I'm facing this on the ones that
I'm actually probably gonna watch I'm
gonna do one of mine on Scream Six I
agree with seems Scream Six and I think
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey might be
uh oh a surprise like big not a lot of
love for both afraid uh you know we
don't know how scary we're not uh we're
not an a24 kind of uh now off-screen
producer John an ice cream producer
dashel are they're gonna be they've
already started camping out for the bows
of great Premiere a phantom menace style
okay we've just got a Roomba moving the
cameras around
okay I think somebody stole a couple of
my knives but that's all right
um do we got 15 on the board
yeah Okay so we've got four for the
killer uh what what are our leaders in
the how many is that for Scream Six
versus Renfield redfield's got two
scripts that's got three okay two for
the so it looks like the order is we're
most Jazz for the killer the David
Fincher film which again we hope comes
out this year has an uh an exactly it
hasn't been announced a lot of love for
Scream Six and then franchise feels like
it's in a good place that trailer was
really cool uh and then you know kind of
equally spread out between Ringfield
Exorcist knock at the cabin Bo is afraid
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey uh it's
gonna be a really good year for creepy
movies you know one thing they've been
talking about a little bit in Hollywood
is not all the genres of film have kind
of fully come back from the pandemic
people are not necessarily going to see
everything uh family films are kind of
struggling uh you know movies like light
year and Strange World and stuff like
that didn't really bring out a big
audience some of the kind of adult
dramas are struggling to bring audiences
but the things that are delivering
superhero movies still put butts and
seats in horror movies right because I
think people love it as a communal
experience you want to go and kind of
like gasp yeah with your friends or on a
date or whatever yeah yeah so um we hope
to see some of these in theaters this
year yeah and I think it works too for
like I remember I saw a Glass Onion
during the Thanksgiving break in a
theater before it came out on Netflix it
was very fun to be in there with the
crowd as like realizations come on you
here they're like oh yeah yeah
there's also something as opposed to
watching on your couch like leaning over
to the person you're with and being like
I know who did it or whatever you know
what I mean yeah I was tired of sitting
on his ass hanging out with his family
at home
theater he wants to whisper of people in
the theaters like I directed that you
know what there's a reason James
Cameron's been married four times I
erased their nipples that was my call
where are the nipples James where are
the blues they don't breastfeed oh not
traditionally they they ponytail feed or
whatever right that's right um hey real
quick uh this is this is authentic I
have an app on my phone called upside
that I use every time I get gas wherever
I am in the city of Los Angeles wherever
you are gasoline I open it up yes yeah
that's right gasoline for my automobile
uh I open up website and I find it shows
me the gas stations that are like nearby
and like the different deals they're
offering oh this many cents off a gallon
this this many whatever and I'm like oh
this this is here's a really convenient
gas station I like and they're giving me
10 cents off a gallon boom I clicked
there go I fill up my tank it knows I
use the credit card it knows and boom it
like shows me hey you say we're going to
give you this many dollars how does it
know uh I don't know but it's great so
and we want to thank upside for
um sponsoring the break room yes all
week that's legit I've been using upside
for months
um they even uh Offset you know it just
like you got to buy gas anyways you
might as well save some money save your
groceries gas up my cruiser and head to
a weekend getaway this would be my first
upside usage I'm very excited and I got
it because of this show because they
sponsored us so you know what I'm not
just a talented host charismatic sex
symbol I'm also a member of the club hey
um to get started download the free
upside app that's the other thing you
have to pay for this app there's no
subscription fee there's there's nothing
right like uh you download it totally
for free and you're off and running use
our promo code break room and get an
extra 25 cents back for every gallon on
your first tank of gas hey if you've got
a 14
uh get I got a 14 gallon tank well it's
pretty it's pretty normal I'm driving a
sedan it's no big deal if you've got a
big SUV or a van or something like that
it could be 20 plus gallons that right
there boom that's saving you a lot of
money yeah uh claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside then
pay as usual with a credit card or debit
card boom follow the steps get paid
collect you can earn three times more
cash back with upside than with most uh
Credit Card Rewards or loyalty programs
um and it's not just gas either you can
use it at restaurants uh grocery stores
I use it at grocery stores uh I fill up
my Wienermobile all the time with it no
it's not the Oscar Meyer one but it is
my car yours is a very graphic
representation yes yes yeah it's fully
authentic it's an Anthony Weiner mobile
okay uh download the free upside app and
use the promo code break room that's
promo code break room to get an extra 25
cents back for every gallon on your
first tank of gas thank you to upside
for sponsoring the show uh guys we've
had a great show and we want to thank uh
so many people for sitting in super
chats uh Vera Morris thank you for your
compliment on my performance on Hunters
I mean it was no secret that I'm gifted
but now though you can see no uh
earnestly thank you painter our old
friend hey happy Friday paint demente uh
Jordan Gonzalez pointing out uh and you
did a great job killed it on Hunters uh
they also pointed out and you should
know this notice this Tommy has the
throat goat that they made note of the
way that the bear and cocaine bear
throated that brick yeah just swallows
that hole oh all right I've made notice
I you can see my throat blog yeah uh
swallowed ground uh does cocaine absorb
if you eat it yeah yeah I mean I don't
know
well there are there I mean there's
stories of you know uh mules yeah oh
sure and it bursts and it bursts yeah
but do you get hired it's just like oh
you get high oh okay uh Christian I I
don't know guys I was uh raised both
Mormon and scientologists so I don't
know uh uh Christian unpronounceable uh
play that finishing thespians graphic
for the chat okay we'll give it to you
we'll give it to you Christian there it
is
and then shout out Derek Edwards Hayden
H uh any change you could get uh after
shows for Star Trek shows on Paramount
plus you know what we love uh we love a
lot of that stuff stranger worlds is
actually strange the world is great I've
enjoyed a lot of Picard dashville really
wants us to do some Star Trek after show
yeah I've screen producer Dash was a big
uh Trekkie you know it's the audience
hasn't quite clicked and maybe don't
have enough overlap with with people
that watch new rockstars but hopefully
fingers crossed that shows the audience
gross maybe more trekkies Come Aboard
you know no pun intended uh and then uh
Jamie Riley uh bummed uh that you don't
get to break room with us on Mondays
well we will be back on Mondays uh
presumably in about nine to ten weeks
yeah for now we're doing a little
something special for The Last of Us
yeah but that's not that doesn't mean
you've seen the last of us it's time for
mandatory fun
you thought we were going to get through
this show without mandatory fun I was
hoping I was awake last night last night
I was lucky enough to take a tour of the
time life building where they make all
those great infomercials you know the
ones where they're like these classic
songs from the 70s 80s and today make
you fall in love again anyway I found a
stack of okay unproduced ballads that
seemed to be written by singers that we
are pretty well known oh wow but that
are also serial killers oh and what's
crazy is
uh I'd like to sing one right now oh
okay great this is actually from Bryan
Adams this is uh to the theme of
everything I do I do it for you oh okay
uh I've heard that song I printed some
up for you guys too in case you feel
inspired to try and join in so Brian
Adams wrote this or a a serial killer I
think Brian Adams is a serial killer
yeah okay sure this was the first draft
maybe yeah a Canadian serial killer oh
you know famously she's a maniac from
the movie Flashdance was just was he's a
maniac and was written for a movie
called maniac and then they cut it out
of that movie and and this is a true
story I'm not making it and bring and
put it into Flashdance where it became a
hit song oh tell me nothing you've said
today is made up I don't know why you
needed to clarify that well we know I'm
a goat let's go
oh
[Music]
start to run
[Applause]
you can escape no matter how hard you
try uh don't tell me you're not worth
killing for
you can't tell me I won't lack all the
good
you know it's true
everything I do is to make a stew out of
you oh
delicious
it broke me
delicious okay all right now Brandon
there was one I found out uh now I'm a
big fan of Billy Joel gonna go see Billy
Joel in concert wait I mean he's also a
killer we know that put it behind the
wheel of a minivan watch out oh my God
anybody who's lived in the Hamptons for
the last 40 years you know he could
strike it anything
Christy Brinkley got out of there just
in time uh but he did you you might not
you might be familiar with Uptown Girl
yes very popular song
the music video a little crazy a little
serial killer asking the music yeah uh I
guess the first draft wasn't about an
uptown girl oh it was about the final
girls no kidding if you know in a horror
movie the Final Girl Is the girl who who
lives at the end or it makes it to the
very end doesn't always live but is
assumed too Jamie Lee Curtis the
ultimate final girl all right so this
was the first draft of Uptown Girl known
as final girl
final girl I killed your boyfriend I'm a
tildo I bet you think he killed me by
the lake but I'm back to stab you with a
stay and when she's running she's
tripping all the time I am and I keep
walking and stuck and I feel so fine
she'll see it's not so bad playing dead
I'm in love with the final girl I'm
gonna take her from this mortal world
I'm getting sick of killing all her
friends oh no she's happy at a pure
revenge and now I'm dead oh again for
everybody tuning in looking for some
Ant-Man the wise quantumania theories uh
you ain't gonna get it here it's Friday
the 13th there's 14 other videos on the
channel that'll get so much more here
like this hit from Bon Jovi oh the ways
that I've watched people bleed stabbing
slicing I got what I need and the truth
is baby you're all I see I Wanna Lay You
Down on a Bed of needles
for tonight I sleep that death himself
we got there he got there he got there
I wanna prick yeah
[Music]
that might have been a poison lyric from
the 80s anyway and last but not least I
think you know Brandon we can uh we can
both be the Tommy role in this oh it's a
little duet written by me I'm not gonna
lie with Zach we co-wrote this together
uh
yeah we took it from our friend uh Kiki
D and Elton John Don't Go Breaking My
Heart uh and uh let's just go for it all
right don't go stabbing my heart
I really want to try I know you think
that you need to kill me the devil told
me I must
the devil told me Satan he told me
when I feel down I chase you around
I'm stabbing your heart
don't go stab him out don't go step in
your heart don't go stabbing you don't
go stabbing your heart don't go stabbing
your heart
[Applause]
thank you all so much for watching uh
Kiana Chanel getting in there with a
late Super Chat thank you Bucky Barnes
ATL thank you for the Super Chat uh this
has been a while as hell uh Friday the
13th episode We Appreciate You Again
watch uh The Last of Us on Sunday yeah
we'll have our after show out Sunday
after the show uh and then uh Eric's
gonna have a full breakdown of the
episode on a Monday yeah again we won't
we wouldn't have been doing a Monday
show anyways because it's a holiday uh
so you're getting a bonus episode on
Sunday there you go yeah and then we'll
be back doing regular
um break room on Tuesday on a Tuesday
don't forget to watch Monday Night
Football check out that new Mandalorian
trailer yeah tons of content around
there and if you order socks 20 at a
time on your Prime you get a free
membership to Prime video click on
Hunter season two episode seven it's
your boy a few nipples yes
uh thank you all have a great weekend
everybody stay safe out there
[Music]